you're not going to believe this but it
turns out that there are people out
there who who don't like me me lovable
me I know I know it perplexed me too so
there are a lot of tick tocks
apparently criticizing and insulting and
attacking me the producers have
assembled them and I will now see them
this video is brought to you by
expressvpn more from them in just a
moment first let's get into it the
internet is full of treasures including
this photo right
right back and said that transgender
people should be eradicated let me hear
from my lawyer posing with a drag queen
on his own Twitter account so put a
pause there I love this I love when the
libs bring up this picture that I took
with a drag queen by the name of Lady
Maga get it like lady Maga Lady Gaga
on the one hand the libs are saying that
I am a genocidal Maniac who wants to
kill every single transvestite that I
ever see and then on the other hand they
think that their Sherlock Holmes that
they've discovered that on my own
Twitter account I once posted a photo
smiling with this prominent transvestite
named lady Maga at politicon a few years
ago at this political conference where
all sorts of people on the left and the
right come out there's that one that
lady Maga who escaped my genocidal grasp
wouldn't you say if that photo is out
there wouldn't you say oh huh maybe
Michael's not a genocidal Maniac maybe
he doesn't hate people maybe he doesn't
want to be really cruel and mean to
people maybe he can be perfectly nice
and pose for a photo with a nice fella
even if the fella is dressed up a little
weird but he doesn't believe in the
Absurd anthropology of transgenderism
and thinks that as it spreads and is
normalized that that would be a good
thing for the country wouldn't you
conclude that no probably you wouldn't
you just you just move right on past
that cognitive distance okay another
gift
Ed started to feel
to feel Ash that comes from calling for
Mass hate crimes against an entire group
of people he tried to say he never said
those things
but my guy we have you on tape we have
your words right here transgender is a
must be eradicated from public life
entirely correct I've said that I did
not only did you say that you didn't go
back and delete the receipts on your own
Twitter account showing how manufactured
your outrage is put a pause there right
I didn't delete the receipts because I
don't want to kill all the transgender
people
one because it's not a real ontological
category and two because I don't want to
go Slaughter and murder anybody I said
exactly what you said I said which is I
call to eradicate transgender is it
which is an ideology that posits that
men can secretly be women which is
obviously not the case I didn't know
that sorry sir ma'am I mean
and so all of the evidence that you are
finding is
proving my point and disproving the
libless headlines of the media which
changed their headlines because they
knew that they would be sued into
Oblivion for the defamation that you're
pretending is is truthful keep going so
the truth Michael is that you're
targeting a population
out this is not an issue you actually
care about and you just got caught in 4k
do better
[Music]
This Woman's saying I don't really care
about transgenderism I'm totally
supportive of transgenderism the proof
of this is I once posed for a photograph
at a political conference with a
right-wing drag queen
okay
so I'm just doing this to get clicks or
something like that the the sometimes
the other version of this is Michael is
secretly a transvestite or a drag queen
or gay or any other number of weird
identities and he's really repressed but
he's I don't know he's just pretending
at CPAC or something like that but the
one conclusion they can never come to is
huh
maybe Michael doesn't hate anybody and
he just thinks that it is a fact of
nature that men and women are different
that's the truth and even if we tolerate
certain degrees of eccentricity and
diversity at the fringes of society we
shouldn't enshrine as a matter of our
law and philosophy and culture the
insane idea that a confused boy should
chop off his genitals to pretend to be a
girl at you that's the only conclusion
that these people can never reach we
have more tick tocks coming up first
though I'm going to tell you about my
friends at expressvpn let me ask you
something when you use the restroom you
always close the door behind you right
you don't want random passersby looking
in on you so why would you let people
look in on you when you go online using
the internet without expressvpn is like
going to the restroom and not closing
the door okay I love expressvpn I'm a
total Luddite so I barely know how to
use any technology but it's so easy to
use even I can use it you just download
it one click of a button on your cell
phone on your laptop on your iPad on
whatever you want I can say with full
confidence expressvpn is the best VPN on
the market here's why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your online
activity they even developed a trusted
server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use that one
button you're done you're good to go so
if you're like me and you believe your
online activity is your business use our
link expressvpn.com Michael YT today and
get three months free on a one-year
package that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Michael YT expressvpn.com Michael y t
how dare you say that I called for the
eradication of transgender people this
is liable but you literally said this on
camera I did not transgenderism must be
eradicated from public life entirely see
I didn't say we need to eradicate
transgender people just the concept of
transgenderism if I said we need to
eradicate poverty or cancer you wouldn't
claim that I'm saying we need to kill
all the poor people or the cancer
patients yes because poverty and cancer
are things that happen to someone they
aren't an unchangeable part of who
someone is trans people can't just
choose to not be trans just like gay
people can't just choose to not be gay
and The Logical conclusion of
eliminating transgenderism is that we
must eliminate trans people wow you know
he was pretty pretty good until that
very last bit where he said transgender
people can't choose between each other
but of course they can most of them have
for much of their lives you can live in
a cord with reality and you can deny
delusions and temptations
jeez come on we all do that to some
degree a man who is married but you know
is he's out at a bar and he sees a cute
girl down the bar and he thinks oh you
know she's pretty good looking he says
no I'm not going to do that I'm going to
say no to that lower desire
because my rational will tells me that I
love my wife and this would ruin my life
and I've made a vow and I have higher
priorities my I'm going to use my
rational will which is conscious and can
reason to suppress my lower will which
is very frequently unreasonable and
repetitive we do that constantly when
you want when you're going to reach for
the third cookie after lunch and you say
no I know my lower will wants that but
my higher rational will says that's
going to make me get fat and have a
tummy ache my stomach hurts so we do
that all the time the other one that
kept cropping up with the speech was
they said what if Michael Knowles had
said he was going to eradicate Judaism
what on Earth has gotten into you and
there's not a comparison between Judaism
and transgenderism because Judaism
refers both to a tribe of people and to
a religious tradition yeah you can you
can eradicate communism as we did that
was the official policy of the United
States for a long time you're not saying
I'm going to slaughter all the
Communists I'm going to eradicate
capitalism it doesn't mean you're gonna
Slaughter all the capitalists finally
those capitalist pigs will pay for their
crimes eh hey comrades hey the libs
probably would like to do that but it's
that's not what that means keep going
this is Michael Knowles's Wikipedia page
it says Michael John Knowles is an
American conservative political
commentator actor author and media host
imagine going to Yale not being able to
leverage any of your connections to
further your acting career end up like a
d-list actor and having to resort to
becoming a conservative political well I
want to put a pause there are you saying
I was on the d-list it's not bad You've
Got a Friend in Me It's funny people all
do sorts of things in their youth they
did a lot of drugs or something
like a mule were they I don't they
became a communist I am once again
asking for your financial support all
sorts of weird stuff for me my wayward
youth was that I was a professional
actor for like two years I worked in New
York I worked in Los Angeles I was in
plays and films and TV you're an actor
you're acting huh now what the libs will
say is
Michael
uh he couldn't get an acting job so he
decided to take up politics uh but that
isn't the the order that things happened
in I was in politics first as a
professional on Congressional campaigns
that Rose to some prominence
presidential campaigns very often the
libs will say well why is it the people
who are in political media often have
some kind of background in performance
or acting or show business or something
why is it that people that are on camera
that speak and perform for a living why
would they have some background in
performance which is you know a very
silly question when you think about it
that way but they used to make this this
joke about Reagan they said oh Reagan
he's a failed actor Ronald Reagan the
actor that's why he had to turn to
politics they made the exact same
argument and Reagan flipped it on its
head and he said how could the president
not be an actor How could a politician
not be an actor the two professions are
really similar and the cynical way of
doing that is that actors and
politicians are both liars and
self-obsessed and vain my opponent is a
liar and he cannot be trusted but I
don't think that's true of good actors
are not Liars good actors tell the truth
in imaginary circumstances that's what
that's what good acting is good
politicians care about the truth and the
way to pursue the good and avoid evil
they love characters they like what
makes people tick good politicians love
other people they love the spaghetti
dinner at the VFW Hall they love seeing
what makes people tick they love hearing
what people care about and they like
helping people
so of course the two go together and
it's no surprise that a great many
politicians have had backgrounds as
actors and in Show Business of course
very similar Fields I fully had not
heard of this man prior to his speech at
CPAC for context and I'm sure most of
you haven't either and then this was his
reaction and then I read the headline
and the headline said
is from Rolling Stone CPAC speaker
calls for transgender people to be
eradicated
did I say that I don't remember saying
that did I hold on let me look through
my speech
poor thing tried so hard it's okay baby
you'll get that sack card one day just
keep trying keep pushing okay excuse me
first of all
I was SAG eligible very early on in my
acting career but the the union is also
just a terrible Union so the Screen
Actors guilders is why a lot of people
left the union it's so funny that the
the lives still extol the virtues of
something like the Screen Actors Guild
or you know these unions it just shows
you how Antiquated or dated the leftist
thinking is it's so stuck in a rut the
unions haven't really helped the film
industry or the education industry or
any of these things in a very very long
time and American labor has kind of
moved past that yet the libs are still
stuck in that same kind of talk
obviously this sexual revolution has not
helped anybody I don't think it's really
helped anybody ever but it hasn't helped
people in a very very long time and now
you've got teachers whining because the
government won't allow them to teach gay
porn in schools and you the Liberals are
still making the same kinds of arguments
oh no
we need the right to Freedom we need the
men can really become women extremely
dangerous to our democracy but it's just
not true and unlike this poor woman
people can hear the plain meaning of
words they know what man means and they
know what woman means and they know what
genocide means and they don't they don't
get really confused seems to be the libs
who are confused
and then they Screech and they wail when
you write over the target
[Applause]
I go between the two hat guy the guy who
was imitating me and the lady Maga one
is my favorite let's give it to Lady
Maga because at least there's another if
not conservative at least
anti-democrat person in the in that
tweet
which I think actually proves my
argument but the libs
just don't understand it okay I'm
Michael Elizabeth Michael Noel show
we'll see you next time
man
[Music]